okay
[Music]
any changes to the declaration of
interest
[Music]
public forum any submissions there you
know
minutes of risk insurance committee held
on the 24th of august
you worship i'll move the minutes
received seconded your worship moved and
seconded any discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye begins carried
minutes of the meeting of council held
on the 24th of august i'd like to move
those you wish uh
mr second day
i'll second that new issue
thank you moved and seconded discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
against carried
minutes of the emergency meeting of risk
and assurance committee
moved your worship thank you on the 6th
of september
second moved in second discussion
questions put it to the vote all in
favor say aye aye
aye against carried
minutes of the emergency meeting of
council held on the 7th of september
moved to worship second intuition moved
in secondary discussion questions put it
to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
carried
minutes of the infrastructural services
committee held on the 7th of september
i'll move that to worship
moved in secondary discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
against carried
minutes of the performance policy and
partnerships committee held
on september the 14th
moves at those minutes to receive your
worship
second
thank you put it to the boat all in
favor say aye aye against carrick
move on to the appointment of the
manufenua seats
now there's some changes there i think
michael was taking us through that thank
you
is that tinakota good afternoon your
worship
uh and councillors um apologies to the
councillors who uh
i'm behind of uh covert um i need i say
more so yes uh think of your worship
there are um two changes that need to be
made um but first i will uh acknowledge
uh the nominees from the urunaka are
here today we have uh pania and evelyn
sitting in the back
um
they have come to observe um
today's session so i thought i would um
bring them to your attention if you
hadn't already
made their acquaintance
so first up
the first change is recommendation eight
so
um and we'll be deleting that
recommendation
and the corresponding section on it and
the report uh will be removed as well
this is under the heading of honorarium
now the reason for this is that
there will be uh brought to the next ppp
committee meeting on the 12th of october
i report for ppp to discuss the level of
honorarium to be paid that will have the
full engagement of both representatives
so that will be an informed council
debate
rather than a setting of staff and this
was degraded in conversation with the
runakha
so that is the two changes for that
other than that
the report
largely sets out the two
uh nominees and the committees that they
will be uh sitting on and some framework
around that so
as evil in order of brevity i am more
than happy to take questions
thank you counselor
thank you worship in order to get the
issue on the table i'm happy to move the
seven recommendations this has been
actually a relatively short turnaround
decision um making process from council
and and that in itself is pleasing so
with one small thing to consider as mr
morrison said which will come up at the
next full ppp meeting in um in a
fortnight fortnight
um so uh again happy to move those seven
recommendations sir
very happy to second those your worship
moved in secondary
council admins
thanks your worship um just want to say
really excited to have this on the
agenda and to be making these
appointments today
it's been a real pleasure to be part of
the
the representation review process that
helped make this happen finally for this
council and i think it's the first of
many really positive steps that we can
be making
to build our partnership with
local ewe so really pleased
thank you
any further discussion
questions yes
i would just like to
endorse those those
accolades and the accolades within the
the roles arrangements and things i
welcome both carly and evelyn i've known
them quite some time and it's lovely to
see them both here thank you very much
thank you
speak
yeah dude michael just some questions
for you
helpful for me
um just want to understand um the voting
rights of the manafenoua roles
so my reading of the local government
act and correct me if i'm wrong is that
they can't vote on full council
correctly thank you
and given that we've transferred that
delegated authority for decision making
to committees which other councils have
not
was it reasonable to assume that the
condition that's in the local government
act for only elected members to vote on
decision-making
issues to also transfer to the
committees as well
so if the matters if something has been
delegated by council
uh to a committee then that committee
has the full right to make that decision
there are only a small number of matters
reserved in a in the local government
act and its schedules that the council
cannot delegate for example the making
of a bylaw so that
making of a bylaw would still be done by
full council where the federal
representatives would not be able to
vote on that but in the committee stage
before for example um infrastructural
they would have a vote on that
but not the making of the bylaw because
the bylaw is only for council
councillor
thank you your worship i've said it
before and i want to say it again
because i think this is a very
significant moment um
this is
a groundbreaking move for this council
i'm proud and pleased to be a member of
the council who's taken this decision i
very much welcome the two
representatives and i look forward to us
working together in the future very
constructively
thank you
thanks uh
thank you worship question
through the chair for michael
at the next
triennium at the next after the forming
of the new council
is it right that the committee structure
can can be altered at that time that's
up to the incoming
mayor is that right or
the
the structure is not set in stone so we
could easily go back to
to three or four committees and that
would have that would allow the ewe
representatives to be on those four
committees just as many as we have
essentially correct yes
thanks
thank you
just a point of clarification
michael we could change that structure
at any time yeah it does not have to
wait until the training but the training
is a reset stage for all councils i was
just reading it as a as a thing that the
committee's structure is determined you
know it's one of those inauguration
things you know yes
thank you any further speakers
now we're removing that as a block are
we yes sir
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carrick
thank you
move on to the project governance group
cheers report
uh chairman thank you for worship so
this is just a continuation of a normal
update from the project governance group
three recommendations the first two
relate to the report itself
and the third one is um on the audio
visual
meeting attendance guidelines
in terms of
the report you'll note that
by the end of the financial year in
terms of the thompson review program
the budget was well under at 243 000
versus a budget of 310
and that
the working group
will have some changes made subject
really to the council's approval which
was done at the last council meeting
on the six-month review
of the thompson report and the pgg will
come back with some
in its next report with regard to those
changes can i just refer
councillors to the
appendix which is
the audio visual conferencing use
guidelines
this this was developed
internally
and really is a reflection of
the bases that increasingly using zoom
as a mechanism and so would like you to
have a look at the guidelines on the
basis of saying it's trying to align
them as near as possible to
the way a physical meeting would take
place and that is just in terms of
obligations around
for counsellors and notifying
when they're using zoom and not being
able to
attend a physical meeting
part of the sort of thinking behind it
was we didn't want to get to a position
where everybody used zoom and only one
person turned up to a council meeting
um it just wouldn't look right
so
these have gone through cheers group
they were initially drafted as i said by
staff and have also gone to pgg
anyone wish to speak to that
to those
um councillor abbott we can't hear you
very well at the moment we're just
seeing what we can do about that
okay thank you
in the meantime you worship to um get
this on the table i'm happy to move the
recommendations
okay mr a seconder
yeah i'll say that
rabbit can you just try speaking again
please we think it might be your end
that has a problem but
um that's always the belief isn't it
okay can you hear me now
yes
a little bit okay uh just bear with me
um
i'll see what i can do
i'm sure there's a reference to this
in the guidelines
some of the issues you might think about
is that um
yet under the new
recommendations you'd have to give
two days notice
of wanting to use
zoom
you
have to
make sure that they
the reason for this is
um
the case the member is unable to attend
because of an emergency
and then you've got to think well what
is an emergency
and for some families
it's a child care issue
and they have to
make sure they're available in case
there's an emergency
and so it
could be argued that
that it discriminates against
people who are involved in home
home care
counsellors
thank you you wish i was just going to
point out that there's
there's actually three um
three reasoning paragraphs
only one of them refers to emergency the
other talks about members being in a
place that makes their physical presence
at the meeting impractical or impossible
which would for instance cover myself
being at an sdhb meeting in dunedin
the second one is the member is unwell
possibly at risk of making others unwell
because of proximity and only the third
one
um
suggests emergency situations so
i feel that it is not particularly
discriminated against anybody
uh
sorry councillor abbott was ready to go
fine
now
it's a bit of an echo to it maybe if you
are close to them it's hard to see where
you are in relation to the microphone
um well yeah just a normal practice
um wellness
is uh
clarity means making others
it's more than that if you look at the
human rights
[Music]
disability and wellness is wellness or
unwellness and wellness and not confined
to close proximity where you may infect
others
so i just want to make that point
you
yeah the speakers counselor care yeah
thank you worship yeah under guidelines
too i just want clarification under a
it states elected members should give at
least two working days notice that they
wish to attend by audio visual learn
well if someone had an unexpected
illness on the morning of a meeting
that doesn't give you can't give two
days notice
and there are other delays of different
kinds like motor vehicle breakdowns and
a raft of other things
and by having that two days clause in
there
uh you're excluding some
probably some very valuable council
members
and they have a great input to these
meetings and we're going to
exclude someone because of this two-day
rule can someone clarify that please
um your worship for the purpose is a
clarification
counselor kits referring to the standing
order the the um
the policy actually says that or the
guidelines state that they are focusing
around that which is already included in
standing orders and the requirement in
standing orders around two days is
section 13.12
i think in all instances
the chairperson's ruling is final and
i'm sure that your colleagues would
understand if you had a motor vehicle
hikapo or an illness that precluded you
from coming but standing orders does
require and the guidelines are
suggesting that
notification to the chairperson would be
the appropriate
step thank you thank you sort of crack
it um thank you worship um i was
actually going to just um this is pretty
much say what what claire has and that
this council has already ratified its
standing orders and did so at the at the
start of the trienium which states that
um if we wanted to attend via
audiovisual link we should give two days
now that's in ordinary circumstances so
if you know you're going to be away and
you need to attend by audio visual link
like perhaps you're on holiday or
i don't know whatever you may possibly
be doing counselor kit it would be in
ordinary circumstances that you would
then notify the chair to say hey look
i'm probably not going to be able to be
there in person can i please have an
audio link
if it was me per se and my daughter was
sick and i needed to rush off and pick
her up and i knew that i was well and i
could attend via zoom i would um of
course not be within that two-day period
but i would then be able to contact the
chair and say can we whip up something
it's an emergency or well you know an
emergency circumstance can i please have
um a link provided so that i can still
participate so it's not designed to
exclude anybody or preclude anybody from
participating it's more so that it sets
some standards for us to all to hold
each other accountable to to the level
of participation that we actually just
expect from each other
yeah well explained uh thanks councillor
cricket i think also uh councillor
under 1312 it does have the ability to
give less than two days working notice
where there's an emergency or
health reasons not being able to give
the notice within the 48 hours
well i was just going to say the same
thing if you read the sentence that
sentence it says where possible so it's
curious where possible you give two days
notice obviously if you can't you can't
see that's what it says
if you read it
possible
sorry counselor partner
no i'm good
thank you
councillor abbott again
[Music]
is
it's useful to draw everybody's
attention to guideline five as well
there are three items down there that
detail the sort of etiquette
that's required
while participating in a meeting by
audio visual link
having the video on although again there
can be variations to that
i know that mr grant had issues with
connectivity from the farm and in that
instance it was appropriate for him to
turn the video off because it gave him a
more stable broadband feed
but if you've got to have if
if you've got to have the video off
if you wish to participate in speaking
it is uh really up to the chair to
determine but i'd say at that point i'd
want it on
and and in fact if you're trying to
signal to the chair that you want to
speak it's obviously really good to
have it on or at least have the ability
to use the raised hand function but
those three uh
etiquette guidelines under 0.5 are worth
noting if you're going to be a regular
zoomer
or even irregular
thank you
any further discussion
questions
thank you i'll put it to the vote you
know
set the three items or um
it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
against
carried
move on now to the rest of the project
governance
group that's the completion of the
report plus your worship
means reporter it was just a brief
comment i was at the mayor's meeting
and
the issue of forestry versus farming
came up
and it's quite a hot potato very
i suppose emotional
issues were arose over the
farmers think that
it's
having a destructive
um
impact on
small communities and
and of course that people who are
planting trees have switched in many
areas to planting totoro
which is
far less destructive to the environment
than
pionus radiata which is more commonly
planted
so i'll move that my report be received
you've consented it any discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
it's carried
be no urgent business
uh well we're moving in now into the
public excluded session
um
in
and your worship uh if you move and
second to go into public excluded and
then adjourn
the intention is that
we could then go to the extraordinary
infrastructural services committee
meeting so the public can observe that
discussion over the three waters
feedback okay
i'll move we're going to public excluded
i was second that with the exception of
um mr grant and mr mckenzie your worship
and could i just observe that mr
o'callaghan will be joining you at
during that session also so to include
him in that
okay
i'll put the motion all in favor say
all aye dance carried thank you
councillors
how long will we return we're just going
to adjourn for long enough for you and
councillor pottinger to move seats
okay let's quick change over that's a
quick change over
have you seen that
let me show you
tonight
to this extraordinary infrastructure
services meeting
um we've already had no we got no
apologies and there is no public forum
so we're going to move on to the
three waters reform feedback
letter
and
firstly i'd like to move that we
received the report can i have a second
of that please
uh councillor munsten i'll put that
emotion all those in favor
against
that is carried right let's move into
the report
and i must say as chair it's a very very
good report i think it covers
off
everything with incredible detail
factual information
and there's no reading between the lines
so thank you very much staff
so mr chair i'm sorry but i wonder if we
could just correct that resolution of
receiving the report you actually need
to receive the report as a major late
item
it wasn't distributed in accordance with
laguema so it is a major later item okay
all right with that correction as we see
the report as a major late item
thank you i'll put the motion in the
second it put the motion call as paper
all right
against carrie
thank you
right i'm going to pass this across to
either
rhiannon or aaron
aaron
thank you chair
um i'll just i guess take a few moments
just to talk through the content of the
report
um as most people are aware over the
past 12 months council has been working
with central government to inform their
three waters reform proposal
this has included the completion of an
extensive request for information
process that was submitted by icc staff
at the beginning of the year
this information along with central
government working closely with scottish
water to learn from their reforms have
been key inputs into the proposal
released early in the earlier in the
year by central government
this proposal was supported by the
release of modeling data which council
staff have now completed a review and
analysis of
it's important to note that there are
still some significant gaps in the
information that central government have
provided to local councils and further
analysis is likely to be needed
in the future
that being said this report collates
feedback proposed to be provided back to
the reform team
based on our review of their proposal to
date
i'll just briefly touch on the key
issues that are highlighted in the
proposed feedback back to central
government
the first of those being around concerns
that have been highlighted by staff
around the data that have been used to
inform central government's models
this uh
i guess the the differences in our
analysis of their data have quite a
profound impact on the projected costs
per customer
under both the proposed entity d model
which invercargill would fall part of
under proposed water reform and the
costs per customer should three waters
continue to be operated and owned by
invercargill city council
two two key areas make a difference
around around that modeling output
one of those is the debt levels that
have been used to inform the model
uh initially the the debt levels that
were provided by invercargill city
council into the original uh request for
information had our three waters debt at
71 million
has done quite a bit of further work
around unpicking our exact figures
around three waters and our actual debt
around that we hold in regard with of
our three waters assets is only around
16 and a half million dollars so that's
quite a significant change from that
original 71 and it's quite a low level
of debt um that we hold on our assets
and also reflects the uh the quite good
state that invercargill's um assets are
currently in
the second key difference differences
around the the costs that have mod been
modelled around what future investment
will be needed in the network for three
waters
in particular uh the costs that have
been modeled by central government have
taken account of what is the national
need for investment throughout new
zealand so they've taken a look at what
all of the costs to bring every local
government area every water supply up to
standard throughout the country are and
then they've allocated a portion of that
cost back to the invercargill area based
on the size of our population our
population distribution
that doesn't take account of the
conditions of our assets what investment
that we have to do
and so that also has a has a profound
impact on those costs that's even after
the figures that invercargill has used
we've actually included some additional
costs that central government haven't
factored in um things like the potential
for reform to require us to
treat our
wastewater discharge to land rather than
to water
even under that we our figures come back
significantly so what that means is that
dia has proposed a
potential cost per household
under invercargill continuing with its
three waters assets in the future of a
bit over five thousand dollars per
household
now invercargill has remodeled that
based on on those changing imports and
has reflected that we think that the
figure is closer to around 1 850 per
household per annum
um
similarly
the costs that
that dia have come up with with regard
to the new entity d
the the proposed entity that
invercargill would form part of
underwater reform
they are proposing that because of the
cost efficiencies that they are able to
achieve that the cost per household per
annum would be approximately one
thousand six hundred and forty dollars
per annum
now that's been modeled very closely off
the experience on scottish water and the
expectation that about 45
efficiency can be achieved by moving to
entity d
now icc having had a look at that has
some concerns around that ability to
achieve 45 in the south island in
particular um and have reflected feed
proposing feedback back to central
government that
a efficiency figure of 20 to 25
would be more realistic
for the south island and that would
increase that um
that proposed cost around what it would
be
for entity d moving forward
the other clear one of the other clear
points that have been noted is that
there is no clear plan of investment
around three waters assets by the
proposed new entity
um so at the moment invercargill city
obviously has a long-term plan where we
set out our renewals our proposed
investment and the community is very
clear on what it can expect for the next
10 years
at this stage the the community would
have no visibility around what the
proposed new entity would be planning to
invest in in invercargill so we've
provided feedback
to proposed feedback to central
government that we expect that that
would need to be provided for the
community to make an informed decision
another key point is around the
ownership model proposed
um for those of you who have been close
to the water reform journey you may
recall that
we started off with public ownership
being talked about under the new reform
model then we've had terms like crown
ownership it's then moved back to local
ownership and now to council ownership
um
we have some cons we've raised some
concerns around the fact that
ownership uh where we won't actually
have direct control over how assets are
invested in have no ability to
uh you know essentially
dissolve the new entity isn't isn't true
ownership um
and similarly
some concerns around if
a potential proposed model that
invercargill city or any local council
would likely still be required to to
bill for the costs of of water on behalf
of the new entity
really does leave us in a bit of a fuzzy
ownership model in relation to that so
we've asked for some clarity
and provided some feedback around the
concept of ownership
another key point is around
affordability
now at the moment while council holds
control of three waters assets and makes
decisions around how to invest we have
the ability to balance
across across the community where we
invest our money whether that be in
community facilities roads
infrastructure uh three waters
infrastructure etc
now if uh control of three borders
assets moves to
entity d
uh obviously
invercargill city council would lose the
ability to to moderate that that total
cost and that total affordability
so we've provided feedback proposed
feedback around um
our concern
on whether or not
the the water reforms will be affordable
under under the new entity and what
measures would be and put in place to to
monitor and control that affordability
for the community
two other items being there is a lot
going on in the local government reform
agenda space at the moment in addition
to water reform we're also looking at
future for local government there's also
a significant reform underway with
regard to the resource management act
we've raised some concerns around all of
these things being done quite quickly
quite an impost on on local authorities
and staff to get their heads around
what's going on and provide meaningful
feedback to central government we're
also lacking information in a number of
key areas
so there's a feedback back to central
government proposed is that there needs
to be some extra time and a slow down to
make sure that appropriate consideration
is given to the broader reform agenda
and finally
as has been
discussed previously there's still a
lack of clarity around whether or not
the ultimate decision of whether or not
to progress with with water reform and a
move to a new entity will ultimately lie
with the community of invercargill or
whether or not that decision will be
made by central government or some other
broader community-based model so again
providing feedback and seeking clarity
from central government around whether
that decision will still remain with the
invercargill community
um
that's all i have chair
thank you erin that has actually ticked
off
99 of uh the entire report thank you
right i'm going to open up uh for
questions and i first off i have council
ludlow
not questions you're looking for
feedback oh feedback feedback sorry
thank you um
look i i'm very happy to endorse
uh recommendation too and i'm speaking
him in favor of it simply because it
represents the position that we find
ourselves in at the moment uh you know
we're being called by many people a lot
of them have email bombed us this
afternoon or from the very same email
address if you have a look
um
we've had emails over over recent months
calling for us to opt in or opt out but
as a reasonable decision maker i'm not
in a position to be able to do that
because i don't have
enough information
to make
a decision and nor have i had the
opportunity to consult properly with the
correct information
with members of the public
as aaron said there are flaws um that
we've identified through a workshop and
the modeling that's been used there
there are gaps
and inaccuracies um in in the
information
um
we're mandated to make decisions
in the best interests of the residents
of the greater invercargill and bluff
area
uh a lot of what the premise behind the
the
three waters reform
is essentially around water quality for
new zealand inc for areas where they
have had uh
issues
with them and they they are very real
but you know as as a decision maker for
invercargill and bluff they are also not
my concern
new zealand inc is the purvey of central
government
um
and if
we find ourselves in a position of
having to decide whether we're opting in
and opting out and whether or not you
know the whole model works if enough
councils opt out the government may well
make a decision well maybe they just
need to get their big boots on and make
the decision because it's not ours
if they're looking for a decision for
what's best for the entire country
um
we've got as erin mentioned a couple of
other significant acts that that are
under review at the moment and i guess
one of the really good things about that
process that we've been through with
three waters from an lg nz perspective
is we have sat at the table with central
government we might not necessarily all
agree with the position
uh that that's been arrived at but
and it's been arrived at with still gaps
in the information but at least we were
part of the conversation and i can't
help but feel a little pressured that if
we don't fall into line with this one
that they're not going to listen to us
for even more important issues around
the local government act itself
and
and what's going to happen with the rma
review
we have the obligations because of the
significant
um financial value of
uh infrastructure to consult if we're
going to
seed sovereignty dare i use that term
to another organization um
and there are no reasonable time frames
available to us that we can use
so you know is government going to
change the rules for us simply to meet
its own
desired outcomes
well they can but i just wish that they
would make that call
at present i can't say whether or not i
want to opt in or opt out i have an
opinion
but i can't make a decision until i've
got sufficient information until those
gaps are filled until better modelling
is being shown or until a call as for to
whom this decision is being made is
arrived at
i think the only thing we can do is
endorse the letter to the minister
pointing out what council has decided
its collective concerns are and i think
as the chair said it's a very well
written letter
thank you
thank you council adelaide
who else do we have council sapper
thanks mr chair i'll i'll make mine a
lot briefer i think there's some very
legitimate questions
that need to be asked on behalf of our
rate payers
they're all encompassed in this letter
this request from the dia was for
exactly that we were asked to provide
feedback and further questions by the
first of october
that's what we're doing we're absolutely
not at the point of opt-in or opt-out
yet we're at the point of gathering more
information
i'm
comfortable with this letter and the
questions that are in it they're all
very legitimate questions that will add
greatly to the information we have on
which to make the ultimate decision when
it comes to that point
thank
you
councilman
thanks um i agree with the previous
speakers um i guess the only couple of
things that i would add is from a
community perspective which is the
perspective that
we make decisions on
using money as the
priority decision making tool is not
always in the best interests of your
community and i think that the
government has probably gone down the
wrong road by trying to use money as
the
the carrot
and as the the thing to compel us to
want to be part of this because as local
decision makers our decision making is
based on a whole raft of things
including community feedback
and not just always about what makes the
most financial sense or is going to be
the cheapest for people i think the
other thing that i'd just like to
comment on is
the government has
has said that this process has been a
co-design process
in my experience when you do co-design
you work with your community right from
the start you don't decide on a avenue
of travel and then try to bring some
other people or groups along for the
journey co-design starts right at the
start and they are actually partners in
the whole journey not just a partner
once you've made the initial decisions
and so for me i think that's the other
place where the government has
has tripped up in terms of this process
and the outcome that they seem to be
getting as a result of the process that
they have undertaken
counselors
how's clark yep um i've got several
issues um
go for it um
just just the second part of that
sentence i do agree with which is
that it's important not to be rushed on
this issue
so maybe something's along the lines
that we support that traditional
investment levels and infrastructure
renewals have created concerns
but we don't want to be rushed
because that implies that we want reform
and so
i hear a lot of commentary from my
colleagues up north that say well the
status quo is uh
not sustainable well status quo means
two things
i mean it talks about council investment
so there are two parts there one is
council and one is investment
so if if the regulator that's coming
with this water authority could have
powers to ensure that we invest the
right amount of money and it was
sustainable to this council then there's
no reason why the council wouldn't
continue to deliver those goods and not
have to cross-subsidize other councils
that are poorly performing
the other issue that isn't addressed in
the letter um is that it seems to me
that we're putting an awful lot of
pressure on increased treatment of fresh
water to safeguard our drinking water
and a lot of a lot of people in this
debate don't realize that of the fresh
water that we
treat only two percent is actually drunk
and so that needs a bit of a rethink
sometimes that is there a better way of
safeguarding drinking water without um
without uh treating the whole freshwater
issue
um i
signaled earlier that i'm not happy with
the stakeholder groups
and their proportionate
voting ability in the zone d
stakeholders
and so that at the moment is split 50 50
between 21 councils on one side
and naitahu on the other side
and so i'm not re rating that as an
issue for this letter
and there will be further opportunity to
um
to discuss at later stage as we get
further down
down the track
the one issue that does concern me is
that
when i look at zone d and i look at the
other zones in the north island it seems
odd to me that we've taken a model which
is the knight tahoe takuwa model that
excludes nelson city tasman and mulberry
and the chatham islands
and so the on the issue of the shadow
islands that came up recently at a
meeting that we had in christchurch with
nike leadership
there was acknowledgement that the
chathams were not well served by the
invasions historically by the taranaki
tribes
so to put them now into a zone with the
taranaki tribes
is really uncomfortable so i don't uh
don't support that
nelson tasman marlborough and the
chatham islands should be out just
because naitah's uncomfortable with them
logically for a purpose of upscaling a
region you want you want to consider
that the whole south island was in there
having tasman being linked to
gisborne napier taranaki area just
doesn't doesn't sit well with me
and the last thing i'd reflect on i
guess is the is the issue that i've come
to the conclusion that we should opt out
if we're given the opportunity down the
track i think the information that aaron
gave which i know is sourced from
michael
was outstanding and the report's very
very good and i know a lot of works gone
into it
but for the dia to be saying to us that
30 years from now our water rates slash
water levees will be 5 000 per year
and for aaron and michael to be saying
it's more likely to be eighteen hundred
and fifty dollars is a massive gap
and it just shows me how informed dia
has been on this issue every time well
claire will know and others have been
zooming in with dia that every time you
talk to the eye the the
the sand shifts
we started off about six months ago with
needing 90 billion dollars
into into the investment right across
the
country the white um the east western
bay of plenty mayors got together with
dia and said look here's our new
long-term plan we can actually deliver
within two days of that that 90 billion
dollars went up to 185 and when i asked
dia well
what was the rationale behind that oh we
just did some rethinking on it i mean
that just doesn't cut with me we've
heard from morrison lowe he gave some
very good feedback and at the end said
it's quite feasible we could stand on
our own given the work that aaron and
michael have done i that reinforces it
even more for me so
my view is that if we get the
opportunity we should opt out and stand
alone but do thank the staff for the
work they put in
thank you councillor clark
um i'll take the the opportunity as
chair
to make a couple of comments and and
these uh opinions of my own i just want
to clarify that
um look to me
after after hearing the various speakers
especially counselor clark
this is this model is is not for
efficiency or for higher standards it's
a model
solely designed for cross subsidization
forget forget about how invocable people
have paid rates for decades maintaining
our 1.2 billion dollars worth of
infrastructure
um
yeah it's it's
it's a strange one this efficiency thing
uh baffles me that they can pick a
number out of 45 considering scotland i
only ever strive to get to 25 and that
was done
by a very intensive um
population it's like having a water
scheme for rosedale apple bq
glengarry and then merging them all
together and i think gee that's a good
idea you know so there's no comparison
with our sparse geography
so i mean it's quite funny when you look
at that shocking ad that runs on tv
it should actually have a slogan a week
jingle that they used at the very
very first telethon i'm not sure many
people can read that can remember that
far back and it says thank you very much
for your kind donation
and and they should run that in the
background um
so that's that's the chairman's uh we
speech on this i'd like to
thank the staff and counselors excuse me
can i just clarify yes um
i'm just wanting to clarify whether we
wanted councillor amundsen's additional
comments around
the focus on the cost message and the
partnership model did we want those
included as comments yeah
general commentary do you just want that
as a general comment would you like to
squeeze it in if you think it's a
valuable thing to include and have got
time
to do that
where would you squeeze that in
we can include it in the content
consider this value in doing that good
local decision making
okay right and
yes council
thank you mr chair i was just going to
make the point that
the sentence counselor clark referred to
about supporting the need for reform
is actually under the heading of the
wider reform agenda
which includes three waters resource
management reform and local government
reform in that context i think
to say that we are actually supporting
reform
is quite legitimate and i would be
reluctant to see that altered
we're not changing we're hard we're
hardly we're hardly saying we oppose
resource management act reform
and at the moment we are not
saying we have made any decision about
the three waters reform we are asking
for more information
um in the
i think the report of local government
reform
we've already made quite clear we are
i think the reform thing says that you
do it in a strategic order that enables
you
uh yes aaron
sorry just in just for clarity just in
relation to the the sentence that
counselor clark was referring to which
is at the top of page 10.
um i think what i'm taking for from that
is that there's a
i guess two ways that you can take the
word reform um being around doing things
differently and also the proposed reform
um so in relation to the comment made by
councillor clark i wondered whether an
amendment to that that first sentence at
the top of page 10
read rather than saying we support the
need for reform um be amended to we
support the need for change in the way
new zealand invests in its three waters
assets
yeah i'm absolutely fine with that okay
anybody else
i'm happy with that okay well we have
that amendment and do we need to have
the exact details for council amazon's
because we will have to
vote on these correct the amendments i
think that um
you can take it all as one
is one right staff have done an
excellent job so far by your
recommendation mr chair i think
that's all right then
okay
right let's get
the good stuff
right
we've already received the report the
recommendation
is that we endorse and endorse the
attached letter to minister mahuta
incorporating any amendments which we
have just
noted
to be seen by his worship the mayor on
behalf of council
and to be there by the first of october
2021 can i have someone remove that one
sounds silently seconded sorry council
clark
i'm going to put that motion all those
in favor
against
that is carried thank you
for that
and that being the only thing on the
agenda i now declare the meeting close
thank you
so
now we are
going to
you